standard cell potential which is also
called standard cell voltage refers to
the voltage of an electrochemical cell
when reactants and products are in their
standard states at a particular
temperature for a zinc copper galvanic
cell solid zinc reacts with copper two
plus ions to form solid copper and zinc
two plus ions
standard cell potential is symbolized by
e naught of the cell where the
superscript not refers to the fact that
reactants and products are in their
standard states for a solid standard
state refers to the pure solid under a
pressure of one atmosphere so we're
talking about pure solid zinc and pure
solid copper
and for a solution standard state refers
to a one molar concentration
so our concentration of copper two plus
ions in solution is one molar and so is
our concentration of zinc two plus ions
and for this zinc copper cell at 25
degrees celsius the standard cell
potential is equal to positive 1.10
volts
now that we've talked about the standard
cell potential for a zinc copper cell
let's look at a diagram of this galvanic
cell
for this cell the anode compartment
contains solid zinc metal
and one molar concentration of zinc two
plus ions in aqueous solution
the anode is where oxidation takes place
so at the zinc electrode the solid zinc
is converted into zinc two plus ions and
two electrons are lost
so this is the oxidation half reaction
for this cell the electrons that are
lost in the oxidation half reaction
travel through the wire
so there's a flow of electrons from the
zinc electrode toward the copper
electrode
the cathode compartment
contains the solid copper electrode and
in solution a one molar concentration of
copper two plus ions and the cathode is
where reduction takes place so at the
surface of the copper electrode the
copper two plus ions in solution gain
two electrons and turn into solid copper
so this is the reduction half reaction
for this cell
if we were to attach a voltmeter to our
two electrodes the voltmeter would read
1.10 volts and this voltage is the
standard cell potential so e naught of
the cell is equal to positive
1.10 volts
and the standard cell potential depends
on the potentials for the two half
reactions that make up the cell so if we
know the potentials for the half
reactions that make up the cell we can
calculate the standard potential of any
galvanic cell and let's see how we could
do that for this particular cell
to calculate the standard cell potential
for our zinc copper cell we're going to
use what are called standard reduction
potentials
standard reduction potentials are
symbolized by e naught of reduction
and these refer to the voltages for half
reactions that are written as reduction
half reactions for example if copper two
plus is reduced by two electrons to form
solid copper
the voltage for this half reaction or
the standard reduction potential is
equal to positive 0.34 volts
and for the reduction of zinc two plus
ions by two electrons to form solid zinc
the standard reduction potential is
equal to negative point seven six volts
we just saw from our zinc copper cell
diagram that copper two plus ions are
reduced to form solid copper so we're
going to leave this half reaction as
it's written however in our diagram for
our zinc copper cell we saw that solid
zinc was actually being oxidized to form
zinc two plus ions so we need to rewrite
the second half reaction as an oxidation
half reaction and that just means
reversing everything and if we're
reversing our half reaction we have to
change the sign on the voltage so if the
potential is negative 0.76 volts for the
reduction half reaction it would be
positive 0.76 volts for the oxidation
half reaction
so now i've changed it to show the
oxidation half reaction solid zinc
turning into zinc two plus ions in
solution and the loss of two electrons
the standard oxidation potential for
this half reaction is positive 0.76
volts
the next step is to add the two half
reactions together so here are all of
our reactants and here are all of the
products notice how two electrons would
cancel out and that gives us copper two
plus ions in aqueous solution
plus solid zinc
forms solid copper and zinc two plus
ions in solution
since we were able to get the overall
equation by adding the two half
reactions together we should be able to
get the overall standard cell potential
e naught of the cell by adding together
the standard potentials for our two half
reactions
so e naught of the cell is equal to e
naught of the reduction half reaction
plus e naught of the oxidation half
reaction which is equal to positive 0.34
plus 0.76 or positive 1.10 volts so the
standard cell potential of our zinc
copper cell is equal to positive 1.10
volts at 25 degrees celsius
we can also calculate standard cell
potential using a slightly different
form of the equation that we just
learned
remember that we flipped the sign of the
standard reduction potential to get the
standard oxidation potential which we
plugged into this equation and were able
to calculate the standard potential of
the cell
instead of flipping the sign ourselves
and getting a standard oxidation
potential we could use this new equation
to just use reduction potentials to
calculate the standard potential of the
cell notice that this new equation has a
negative sign that essentially flips the
sign of the standard reduction potential
for the oxidation process so it
accomplishes the same thing that we did
ourselves in the first equation
so to find the standard potential of the
cell we take the standard reduction
potential for the reduction process and
from that we subtract the standard
reduction potential for the oxidation
process so this equation is a bit of a
shortcut so when we plug in our standard
reduction potentials of positive 0.34
volts and negative 0.76 volts the
negative sign means we end up with the
same answer we got before positive
1.10 volts